all right Luanne two years into Countess
and friends yes
can you believe you've been touring for
two years it's incredible it's just I
just love it you know doing Christmas
shows coming up I've got an all-new show
coming up in January called Mary F kill
so it's a lot of fun creating new shows
and and I'm just having a blast what
does Mary F Hill mean for the show how
is it going to change from the countess
in trends we've seen well you know it'll
be more about sex relationships and then
of course okay so maybe some news
stories and of course the new stories
new music yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to hash counters and friends 54
below yeah - now see these big shows
you're selling out did you have even
like a glimmer of a thought that that
would be where this was headed no I had
no idea in fact when I did 54 below you
know I said to my agent I want to keep
it small cabaret style tables and things
like that and he's like no no no no
you're gonna go into big theaters and I
was like really you think so I know and
and so it just has I'm just as amazed as
as most people are you brought up your
agent who I believe you might be dating
okay well I am you know he's he was on
the West Coast and I live in New York so
you know it's a bit of a back and forth
but but we're dating that's really nice
how does the back-and-forth work is
long-distance tricky well I think that
you know I'm traveling a lot with the
cabaret shows so so it's not always easy
but I think at least your agent gets it
because he's the one who booked it so
yeah so he's very supportive and he's
just a great touring agent and he's got
really you know great clients Randy
rainbow being one of them and Theresa
Caputo who does her live shows so he's
just he's a great guy lucky how'd you
make the shift from professional
relationships a personal relationship
believe me it wasn't easy it was like no
I'm not that's not happening and then he
just wore me out okay so he was putting
in the water yeah and and you know it
just turned into a really great working
relationship as well as as a romantic
one so is that tricky to navigate at all
you know it hasn't been so far so so far
so good okay so far so good
how long has it been well um like a year
and a half Wow yeah my shows been almost
going on two years now and you know took
about five months in until before I gave
in so you were able to keep that pretty
under wraps for a long time yeah I'm not
a nice change of pace well yeah and you
know I just
[Music]
were just dating at the time and and
continued to date and I just wasn't sure
where it was going so so I didn't really
talk about it yeah yeah no it sounds
like it's going somewhere exact it's out
there you want to get married again you
know listen I never say never I'm a
hopeless romantic I was married twice
already and they say three time's the
charm so you know who knows who knows
I'm not in a big hurry to do anything
right now I'm just enjoying the moment
yes enjoying cabaret life exactly
enjoying the relationship yeah well
that's great
does he have the kids stamp of approval
yes he does okay cuz that's a big that
is big that's big well we see the
relationship at all on the show or is
that something you're keeping away from
cameras no you know no I talk about him
but no you won't okay there's the
balance between exact personal also
celebrating probation is over yes
finally after all this time yeah does
that feel like a weight has been lifted
off Oh totally you know even though
things were going really well with my my
shows and everything else you know that
was weighing heavily on me and so that's
finally behind me and and I'm you know
I'm writing a book about the journey
because let me tell you it wasn't an
easy one and and I think a lot of the
reason why people are so into the show
is I you know I talk about it I joke
about it in my show I self-deprecating
out it because it was such you know
tragedy for me and and so you know now I
make light of it because it happened
it's behind me and and I think there's
lessons to be learned from it and you
know I'm still learning those lessons
and and plugging them into my life and
and you know just live and day by day
what would you say is the biggest lesson
you've taken away from that experience
well I think the lesson for me was I was
running fast and you know just to slow
it down to you know get back in control
of my life
you know not only be on the stage but
take center stage of my life and so I
feel like I'm in the driver's seat now
and I'm in a really good place and life
is good and you're on watch it happens
live at Bravo con you could hear Tinsley
shouting in the back
she can drink she can drink what does it
feel like to close that chapter of your
life I can move on with my life and be a
badass with all the Housewives of New
York yeah I know Tinsley loves to say
but I take it day by day and it's not
you know my focus is on my cabaret and
obviously I couldn't have this career if
I was a hot mess
right so yeah so you're just taking it
day by day
exactly all right sober right now yep
bring it up Tinsley she's engaged to sky
[Music]
yeah finally I'm glad for her you know
it's been a long time coming
God knows we've been back and forth
about Scott and all that and I'm happy
for her you know I'm I hope it works out
because they've had their ups and downs
and I hope this one is going to stick
and it's here to stay all right
I mean speculation is this means she
will no longer live in New York which
means can no longer be a constant right
well we'll see where that goes you know
obviously you no one makes a choice in
life and and you know I don't know where
she's gonna land I just you know I wish
her the best and and hope that she has a
long romantic wedded blissful life did
she send a group text out ladies that
happened no okay she didn't actually um
but you know I knew it was inevitable I
saw her watch what happens live you know
it provoked on and and so she would look
really happy and and and I think that
you know that's it's it's finally
happening
right and excited for her this thing
she's wanted for also at Bravo con you
got to help introduce your new co-star I
brought along the newest Real Housewife
of New York City Leah McSweeney
what do you need to know about Leon
before the season starts well you know
what's great about Lea is it's not an
easy group of women to walk into and I
think that she can hold her own I think
that I think people will like her she's
different she's you know downtown she's
younger
she's a young mom she's a you know so
she's a mom you know we'll see her
family life
she's also vulnerable and I think that's
very important because you feel like you
get to know her and you know we can all
relate to her which is really important
for being a housewife and so I think she
makes a good addition to the cast
what's her entry point to the group
who's the person Tinsley okay yeah
interesting yeah but I liked her as soon
as I met her I really liked okay to go
yeah I did
I mean she's being probably unfairly
dubbed Bethany's replacement right
is there any replacing Bethany or should
we judge Leah on her listen you know
nothing he's been replaced as a
replacement yeah of course there is um
you know Bethany is you know been a huge
character on the show she's come and
gone herself from the show so so you
know wishing her the best as well you
know everybody's got their life and and
you know she chose to leave and and so
we were all just surprised by it we
found out just like you right just like
you did so we were kind of surprised and
shocked by it and you know like I said
she's doing her thing and wish her the
best
you still in contact with her I haven't
heard from her personally but I think
some of the girls are okay yeah you did
say I'm Jenny McCarthy's show that
learning that Bethany wasn't coming back
was kind of like a sigh of relief well
yeah I think there's a lot more
breathing room now that because you know
Bethany took up a lot of air in the room
and and so I think you'll get to know
that other women better there's more
room for them to express themselves and
so you know we have a great season
coming up and so I'm excited you also
said on that Jenny
the interview this is insider scoop we
go to a fashion show right and there is
a place set for Bethenny Frankel at this
fashion show while we're filming and
Ramona freaked she's just scared of her
she's terrified of Bethenny well she
says it herself but I had Brava con she
told me I think I'm the only person
who'd stand up against Bethenny oh the
other girls are just kiss her ass oh
really
I I don't know I you know she she she
has said to us before that you know and
has said it and put it out there so
she's had a change of mind that's Ramona
that's that's Ramona I know there's no
trailer or anything out so now you have
to keep a big butt what are you most
excited for the fans well I'm excited
that you know they will see both the
relationships and how they've changed
and Dorinda and I are very tight on you
know we have a crazy trip always to the
preserve shores and and of course go on
our cast trip so there's you know
there's a lot of drama there's a lot of
fun and you know we have deep
relationships you know we've known each
other a long time so it's always
interesting to watch because you know
it's like family you fight and at the
end of the day you have to sit down to
Thanksgiving table right and eat
together so so it's it's a great season
there's a lot of really fun stuff and a
lot of drama last year we did get to
meet your pal Barbara oh yeah I don't
really want to talk no longer your pal
yeah okay that's we've kind of seen it
all so yeah yeah
so we won't be seeing Barbara you make
the same promise
I imagine we'll get to see the creative
process behind Mary f kill yeah so some
developing of that new show well and
also I'm working on a new song with
Desmond child okay yeah super exciting
another dance track another dance track
a little different from what I've done
in the past so super excited could you
take inspiration from your catchphrase
is and that connects so what is he a
hint at what this one's about it's about
it's a little bit about divas okay okay
yeah are you gonna catch any flat for
lumping yourself in with divas and I
think you know listen I think
diva is not an egg
word I think it's somebody who who you
know thinks that they're just as good as
everybody else if you don't think you're
great nobody else well isn't that right
hey you said it was a Christmas track
you know what so funny I spoke to my
producer who did money and cheek with me
and he said we are doing a Christmas
album next so you'll see that Ferb
okay so 2020 I guess 2020 there we go
I'll leave it on that thank you
[Music]